merci jean noël j'ai l'honneur d'animer
cette table ronde et je vous avoue que
je me sens très petit surtout à côté de
titres et conscience et responsabilité
l'ambition démocrate je vais les
questionner mais je vais surtout vous
proposer de les questionner à votre tour
et je commence tout de suite avec
patrick mignola
alors patrick mignola vous êtes député
de savoie et président du groupement
démocrates et démocrates apparentés en
mars 2021 l'opinion titre à votre sujet
patrick mignola la tête brûlée de la
majorité le figaro ensuite en mai 2021
le bulldozer du modem au palais bourbon
on vous reprocherai presque d'être
honnête et par votre honnêteté votre
liberté c'est ce que disait ici même en
2018 celui qui vous avez succédé marque
fait nous nous sommes libres et loyaux
et parce que nous sommes vraiment libres
sont vraiment loyaux et est votre
ambition
patrick mignola veut démontrer même avec
de nombreuses sensibilités au sein d'un
même groupe qu'il était possible de
parler d'une seule voix
conscience et responsabilité
c'est ça ouais nan mais pauline à raison
j'ai pris une résolution pour 2022 à la
demande unanime des députés du groupe
c'est que désormais bulldozer tête
brûlée maintenant c'est fini je vais
être docile et déférent dans une blague
évidemment
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça va se
passer parce que c'est pas la marque de
la maison en revanche en effet c'est
intéressant d'avoir vu ce groupe grandir
parce que chacune et chacun de ses
membres ont grandi au cours de cette
législature
avec beaucoup d'épreuves à traverser et
puis grandir aussi en nombre avec un
certain nombre de d'amis
qui se sentaient appartenir à cette
famille politique soit parce que ils
venaient lointainement de la même
famille du centre ou tout simplement qui
sont venus d'un peu plus à droite d'un
peu plus à gauche et c'est extrêmement
intéressant de voir comment le groupe à
trouver une cohérence parce que il ya
deux façons de trouver des cohérences
soit on se ressemble à 100% on a une
sorte de de génétique commune
soit on peut avoir aussi des capacités
de deux déplacements parce que à défaut
de se retrouver sur les chemins les
parcours respectifs de chacun on se
retrouve sur les objectifs et le les
députés du groupe qui au fond sont très
représentatifs pour avoir vécu toutes
les aventures que nous avons traversé au
cours des 20 dernières années
parmi ses objectifs
ils ont sept cette passion
de ce grand centre humaniste
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu clément
clément bonne
keanu très bon ministre ce fait nos d'un
gourou impériaux sec al-hameli passe mal
et
au sein de nos amis de l hérault m dire
qu'au fond on était
le parti de la raison
c'est vrai parce qu'on peut avoir
parfois des oppositions déraisonnable
selon l'as vécu cet été quand on a voté
le pass sanitaire c'était extraordinaire
de voir à quel point nos oppositions se
comportait de façon irresponsable et on
avait le parti socialiste qui écrivait
un avis au premier ministre et qui faute
est exactement l inverse de son avis
quand il arrivait dans l'hémicycle on
avait l air qui était arrivé à faire
voter son groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale à linverse de ce
qu'avaient votées le groupe
parlementaire de l air au sénat
et donc effectivement il ya de la raison
mais il n'ya pas que la raison il ya
aussi une très grande passion
et au moment où nous avons décidé de
nous engager dans une meilleure
structuration de cette grande famille
centrale au coeur de la vie politique
française je pense que c'est ça qu'il
faut garder à l'esprit
l'idée que nous défendons les valeurs
que nous portons de de liberté de
justice sociale d'engagement européen de
mobilisation autour d'eux des enjeux
écologiques
ça se fait aussi avec une grande passion
en étant conscient que l'idée qui
apparaissait comme généralement répandue
que la démocratie avait gagné en mode
dans le monde avait gagné en france
et est devenu aujourd'hui une idée à
nouveau contesté
et je l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises au
cours de ces deux jours ce qui s'est
passé en afghanistan aura évidemment des
conséquences géopolitiques mais ça aussi
une conséquence dans le débat public
mondial c'est que d'aucuns peuvent
prétendre que la démocratie l'humanisme
le respect des femmes
c'est une valeur relative qui ne serait
pas adapté
tous les peuples à toutes les cultures
est tous les territoires nous pensons
exactement l'inversé nous pensons que ce
combat non seulement c'est un combat
politique pour nous mais c'est un
message universel de la france au reste
du monde et au moment où on va présider
l'union européenne à partir du 1er
janvier prochain ce combat-là niveau
pour le monde vaut pour l'europe et ne
vous y trompez pas il faudra aussi dans
le débat public présidentielle parce que
à notre droite comme à notre gauche on
voit bien la nouvelle obsession à droite
vous avez des obsessions de plus en plus
identitaire
et à gauche vous avez des obsessions des
constructivistes wow kyste qui fonde
victimaire
cette approche qui au fond enferme les
personnes dans ce qu'ils sont dans ce
qu'ils furent ou dans leur origine alors
que nous pensons au contraire qu'il faut
pouvoir les projeter vers l'avenir et
les faire ressortir de leur être
françois dit la plus belle phrase hier
c'est que quand on est humaniste on
essaye de faire de trouver l'homme dans
l'homme et de faire dans l'oms ressortir
l'homme
et c'est cette démarche qu'on adopte
aujourd'hui je pense que tout simplement
dans ce groupe parlementaire que j'ai eu
le grand honneur de présider et dont
nous ferons tout pour que non seulement
ils puissent être reconduits pour
chacune et chacun d'entre eux mais qu'
il puisse s'étendre encore grandir
encore pour convaincre encore plus au
fond la marque de fabrique et c'est ça
qui nous permet de nous retrouver
pauline même en étant dans des chemins
différents c'est qu'au fond ils ont le
goût des autres qu'ils ont le goût de
l'avenir vous avez vu tout ce qui s'est
déroulé cette semaine et je terminerai
par là on a eu un grand débat entre
zemmour et mélenchon on avait
l'impression d'assister à un débat entre
maurice thorez et jean louis tixier
vignancour tout ça c'est le passé bien
ils se querellaient d'ailleurs sur le
passé on avait l'impression qu'ils
parlaient au temps que les moins de
vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître c'est
à dire ceux du pacte de varsovie
c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut faire de
la politique et si vous regardez ce qui
se passe dans nos opposition dite
républicaine à droite et à gauche les
seules idées qui sont ressortis de cette
séquence des primaires se sont au fond
les programmes de nicolas sarkozy et de
ségolène royal de 2007 et nous on n'a
pas envie de cette forme de retour vers
le futur quand vous regardez d'ailleurs
la décision qui a été prise hier par nos
concurrents de l est
d'organiser une primaire mais refermés
sur eux-mêmes comme s'il avait peur du
peuple
et une primaire dit de la droite et du
centre on sait ce que c'est avec les
élèves la droite et le centre c'est la
droite triomphante et le centre coucher
c'est précisément pour ça qu'on s'était
engagé auprès de françois bayrou depuis
tant d'années mais là c'est n'aime pas
le centre couché c'est le centre absents
moi je vous invite à dire à nos amis
centristes qui était resté auprès des
élèves que nous la maison est ouverte et
qu'au lieu de ne pas avoir le choix
du candidat qu'il pourrait soutenir
qu'ils viennent avec nous pour que nos
idées l'emportent et c'est comme ça
probablement qu'on fera encore grandir
ce groupe parlementaire
merci patrick jacqueline gourault
vous êtes ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
vous êtes connu et reconnu pour traiter
avec calme chacune des discussions et
chacun des dossiers que l'on vous confie
et force est de constater que c'est une
réussite comment pouvons-nous selon vous
satisfaire une des ambitions premières
de notre mouvement bâtir une société
plus apaisé
tout un programme
une société plus apaisée c'est vraiment
effectivement un objectif que nous
devons tous rechercher
parce que nous savons bien que il y a
beaucoup d'inquiétudes
qu'il y à beaucoup d'interrogations
dans notre société et notamment
vis-à-vis
du monde politique et des institutions
et des autorités
en général et donc
notre famille politique a un devoir
de réflexion bien sûr mais un devoir de
pédagogie aussi alors j'aime beaucoup la
pédagogie sa médaille en sait quelque
chose que j'ai pratiqué aussi pendant
longtemps
et je pense que notre pays a besoin
aussi de et nos concitoyens et à
commencer par les élus également locaux
a besoin
à la fois d'entendre
et d'écouté et de transmettre
à nos citoyens en effet on est dans un
monde où le populisme c'est à dire
au fond l' arrangement
avec la vérité
l'arrangement avec la conscience et la
responsabilité puisque c'est le titre de
cette table ronde est vraiment malmené
nous avons des responsables politiques
qui peuvent
aussi
[Musique]
comme on dire à longueur de journée
d'hier des contre vérités sur les médias
avec
je dirais une certaine morgue puisque
ils savent bien que ce qu'ils disent est
faux mais qui entraîne qui tire la
société vers le bas donc nous notre
famille politique
celle doit enfin je crois se situe
exactement
dans la démarche inverse c'est à dire
que nous avons un devoir de toujours
expliquer dire la vérité tirer vers le
haut et aussi à voir
je dirais un comportement c'est très
important un comportement une manière
d'être qui
permet à nos concitoyens de retrouver la
con la confiance est la conscience de la
vérité de ce qui se passe dans notre
société et dans la mission qui est la
mienne au ministère de la cohésion des
territoires c'est un combat quotidien
d'expliquer aux élus locaux que la
france est un pays dans lequel les
grandes réalisations se sont toujours
faites dans l'alliance entre les
collectivités territoriales et l'état je
les ai déjà dit hier d'une autre manière
dans un autre cadre mais je crois que
c'est quelque chose
de très importants et donc lutter contre
le populisme c'est quand même une de nos
missions
essentielles
et rassembler toutes les familles du
centre qui partagent cette vocation
c'est quelque chose de très important
alors tout à l'heure
patrick a raconté ce qui s'était passé
dans la décision pour parer l'air de se
refermer pour choisir leur candidat aux
élections présidentielles
moi j'y vois et on en parlait avec
françois hier soir avec marc etc j'y
vois une grande
une grande commande un grand intérêt au
delà de leur bêtise qui montrent leur
fermeture d'esprit
c'est que peut-être enfin on n'entendra
plus parler de d'un parti qui représente
la droite et le centre puisqu'ils se
sont ils ont verrouillé eux mêmes ils
ont fermé à clé
leur maison et ils ne pourront plus dire
après avoir rejeté ceux de nos ex amis
qui s'étaient laissés tenter par
comment dire le fait de rallier une
majorité d'alors
eh bien je crois qu'aujourd'hui le grand
avantage parce qu'il faut toujours
trouver des avantages à aux fautes des
autres
c'est que au fond le centre les centres
et que nous cherchons à
rassembler depuis si longtemps
vont je pense être libéré je pensais à
certains de nos petits camarades ça doit
leur faire drôle et doivent se poser des
questions je sais pas s'ils ont réagi
puis hier parce que j'ai un peu dormi
cette nuit mais je
pense que c'est un grande une grande
évolution de notre vie politique et je
dois dire je pas si c'est le fait des
annonces
de françois bayrou et de richard ferrand
hier qui les a tapez anisé je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas il est certain que
ils ont là
au fond fait un geste vous pris une
décision qui au fond leur ressemble
depuis toujours et qui montre que
ceux qui l'ont essayé
de faire depuis longtemps
c'était un mirage et que c'était
simplement la volonté
de faire disparaître le centre dans
notre pays et d'avoir cette alternative
binaire qu'ils ont toujours recherché
entre
je dirais la droite et la gauche
classique et bien non c'est parce que
nous voulons la conscience de ce que
nous sommes puisque au fond c'est ça la
conscience de ce que nous sommes
nous nous oblige je dirais à dire
aujourd'hui que ce que emmanuel macron a
réalisé par son élection en 2017 est ce
que nous allons continuer à faire dans
notre vie politique et à construire dans
notre vie politique
notre responsabilité devant les français
enfin conscience et responsabilité
c'est indissociable partir du moment où
on a conscience ce que nous sommes qu'on
a conscience de l'état de notre pays
notre responsabilité est bien c'est bien
celle de construire le grand centre je
vous remercie
[Musique]
alors jean noël barrot vous êtes député
des yvelines secrétaire général de notre
mouvement le mouvement démocrate depuis
maintenant trois ans le président
françois bayrou l'a dit lors de
l'ouverture de notre université un parti
politique est un courant philosophique
une vision du monde qui ne ressemble à
aucune autre du temps quelque chose le
chef d'orchestre qui avait beaucoup de
coeur associe l'ensemble de nos
militants cadres et universitaires et
une réflexion sur les valeurs et la
pensée démocrate alors j'en donnerai ma
question est simple qui sommes nous
alors c'est vrai que gg quand j'étais
petit mon rêve c'était de devenir chef
d'orchestre mais je remercie françois
noir permis à défaut d'être secrétaire
général est de pouvoir avec toute
l'équipe qu'on a remercié tout à l'heure
organisé cette université de rentrée qui
sommes nous nous sommes les démocrates
et si nous traversons père et mère pour
nous retrouver chaque année à guidel
c'est parce que nous croyons à la force
de ce grand courant démocrate qui
irriguent avec constance la vie
politique française et oui on nous a
longtemps catalogué comme des modérés
des indécis le filet d'eau tiède le
centre mou le grand méchant mou mais ce
que nous disons au contraire c'est que
le projet que nous portons est
radicalement différent de celui des
autres familles de pensée de la vie
politique française notre vision de
l'homme et de la femme comme un être de
raisons de conscience un noeud de
relations qui par l'exercice de la
responsabilité de la liberté accède à
l'émancipation qui est la finalité de
toute action publique et à la gauche
qui prisonnière de la tradition marxiste
se donne comme seul horizon
l'égalisation des conditions matérielles
nous disons nous
que les aspirations humaines sont
multiples et qu'il faut tenir compte de
cette complexité pour concevoir de
bonnes politiques à une droite qui s'est
construite par accumulation de sédiments
bon à partie ce conservateur néolibéraux
et qui est bien à la peine aujourd'hui
nous disons que la vitalité démocratique
repose sur la qualité que les sites de
l'école et des liens que les citoyens
tissent entre au sein de communautés
vivantes et que le pouvoir doit être
déconcentré qui doit être partagé qu'il
doit être répartie et qui doit être
installé là où il exerçait avec le plus
la plus grande justice est la plus
grande efficacité que ce soit vers les
collectivités locales où que ce soit
vers l'europe et 7,7 autre solution pour
citer l'un de nos grands classiques cet
autre solution était défendue avec
ardeur par une longue chaîne l'esprit
visionnaire convaincu qu'une autre voie
est possible
un autre projet de société ce que nous
appelons le projet démocrate alors on va
nous dire aussi tout ça ce sont des
paroles des mots toujours des mots
encore des mots mais il suffit de se
retourner quelques instants sur notre
histoire pour s'apercevoir de l'ampleur
des avancées et des conquêtes que notre
courant a apporté à la france
la politique familiale
lives et j'ai les apl la liberté de
l'enseignement la construction
européenne la moralisation de la vie
politique l'intéressement et la
participation
toutes ces réalisations ce sont les
nôtres et elle témoigne de ce que ce
grand courant à apporter à notre pays
et puis il suffit de se retourner sur
les quatre années qui viennent de
s'écouler pour s'apercevoir qu'avec
emmanuel macron avec nos ministres avec
nos parlementaires patrick en parlait à
l'instant avec nos partenaires de la
république en marche nous avons réalisé
nous avons concrétisé un certain nombre
d'engagements qui étaient les nôtres
depuis longtemps premier texte de la
législature la loi sur la moralisation
de la vie politique portée par françois
bayrou dans la foulée la réforme de
l'apprentissage le dédoublement des
classes la priorité donnée à l'éducation
un peu plus tard le pas en avant le pas
le grand pas en avant sur la
construction européenne avec le budget
commun et la dette commune des des états
membres de l'union européenne
la participation citoyenne dont marc
fesneau et le premier ministre si je
puis dire le premier ministre de la
participation citoyenne et on pourrait
citer aussi le nouvel acte de
décentralisation que nous allons
examiner et qui sera porté par
jacqueline gourault au parlement toutes
ces réalisations
jusqu'en 2017 étaient nos espérances et
bien sous ce quinquennat elles seront
devenus réalité alors évidemment nous
pensons que notre projet ne s'arrête pas
là qu'il est en quelque sorte inachevé
et nous continuerons à nous battre pied
à pied pour un renouveau démocratique
qui garantissent le pluralisme qui
renforce le poids du parlement nous
battrons pour rendre l'europe aux
citoyens comme on l'a dit hier pour
mettre sa puissance au service de la
paix de la sécurité du développement
nous nous plaiderons pour une écologie
humaniste on en a parlé vendredi pour un
modèle de développement qui donne les
mêmes opportunités à chacun et puis nous
défendrons toujours toutes les
solidarités à tous les âges de la vie le
soutien aux familles la préservation de
notre système de retraite est la
question du grand âge et pour que ces
idées là pour que nos idées restent au
pouvoir si je puis dire en 2022 puis en
2027 puis en 2000 32 puis en 2037 et
ainsi de suite le moment est sans doute
venu de rassembler les forces démocrates
éparses et d'unifier ce grand courant
de la vie démocratique de la vie
politique française et c'est pourquoi
l'appel de françois bayrou prend tout
son sens aujourd'hui et c'est pourquoi
la décision de notre conseil national
vendredi
de faire un pas en avant dans cette
direction est une nouvelle importante
pour notre famille politique et c'est
pourquoi nous espérons sherston qu'à son
tour la république en marche dans les
jours qui viendront va faire un pas dans
cette direction
merci gendrey parce que j'en finirai là
parce que jean finira là ce qui nous
divise et évidemment bien plus petit que
ce qui nous rassemble est ce qui nous
rassemble ce sont les idées les idées
sur l'homme les idées sur la démocratie
les idées sur le monde et comme on le
dit à pau les idées mènent le monde
merci geneviève darrieussecq vous êtes
ministre délégué auprès de la mise
désarmé en charge de la mémoire et des
anciens combattants en juillet 2020 vous
avez déclaré à la presse l'histoire doit
être dite telle qu'elle s'est passé elle
ne se refait pas et à une part de
tragique et d'injustice il faut la
connaître n'est ce pas cette vérité de
fait qui fait de vous une vraie
démocrate
il connaissait pas les questions
alors là franchement
elle est pas mal elle ne m'avait pas du
tout dit que ça se passerait là
oui je crois que moi ce qui m'intéresse
dans
dans dans ce que je fais dans ce
gouvernement c'est toute la partie
mémoire et pauline a dit un mot et la
mémoire elle s'arrête pas la mémoire des
conflits les mémoires des combats je
pense qu'il ya la mémoire des
territoires aussi il ya la mémoire des
des gens des des hommes et des femmes
qui qui habitent sur nos territoires et
je suis je suis frappé dans les
différents déplacements dans
les les lieux tous les endroits où j'ai
pu aller depuis quatre ans et demi
je suis frappé par à la fois cette
diversité la diversité de la france
la diversité de ses identités en
définitive la diversité de son
patrimoine soit un patrimoine chapelle
saint patrimoine culturel que ce soit un
patrimoine de pierre bien sûr mais un
patrimoine environnemental un patrimoine
linguistique un patrimoine ce qui
concerne l'art de vivre le mode de vie
et un pain est en définitive un
patrimoine très humain les hommes et les
femmes qui habitent dans nos campagnes
dans nos villes dans nos différents
départements et je vois bien
qu'elle est là la difficulté alors moi
je suis dans un jeu dans un sud-ouest où
souvent des des
manifestations qui parle de tradition de
patrimoine de d'art de vivre et
d'incompréhension du reste des élites
par rapport à ces situations de vie sur
nos territoires je crois que notre grand
enjeu d'abord nous les démocrates je
crois d'abord que nous sommes
respectueux nous sommes respectueux des
hommes et des femmes nous sommes
respectueux de leur vie de leur histoire
de leur mémoire et ça c'est très
important et nous ne sommes pas nous ne
sommes ni démagogues parce que c'est
facile de faire de la démagogie sur ces
terrains
ni populiste parce que c'est encore plus
facile pour clivé les situations et le
grand enjeu que nous allons avoir dans
les parlait beaucoup de fractures
territoriales entre la ruralité
les villes et les métropoles en fait ce
sont deux mondes qui ne sont pas si
différents que ça mais ce sont deux
mondes qui ont besoin de se respecter
les uns les autres d'apprendre à se
connaître et qui ont besoin surtout
d'une attention particulière
donc comment comme en définitive nous en
notre enjeu va être important comme en
définitive
quand on nous parle tradition quand on
nous parle
de certaines cultures locales qui qui
sont
plus que centenaire qui sont même très
ancienne comment très simplement tenir
compte
de cette identité qui est importante
pour les populations sur ces territoires
et comment faire en sorte que nous
avancions tous dans l'évolution
sociétale la modernité et que chacun
sente qu'il est à sa place et qu'il
garde sa place et ça c'est un vrai enjeu
parce que les crispations territoriale
qui se font jour ou qui existe depuis
bien longtemps elles sont souvent liés à
ce sentiment de des considérations et ce
sentiment de 2,10 respect par rapport à
certains modes de vie ou à certaines à
certaines situations locales donc nous
avons nous avons cet enjeu qui est un
enjeu en définitive très très simple qui
peut se résumer en une chose ces gens
parlaient un petit peu hier soir avec
les les jeunes dans le débat que nous
avons eu hier soir c'est tout simplement
comment formation et comment faire
nation avec toute notre diversité
en respectant ses diversités et en les
faisant avancer vers un objectif qui est
un objectif fort c'est un objectif
démocratique c'est à dire que nous avons
en fait une perle dans nos mains celle
entre démocratie notre république avec
ses valeurs avec
tout ce qu'elle entraîne comme je veux
dire comme com
[Musique]
véritable avancée époque et ça a été une
grande avancée pour l'humanité et quand
je regarde ailleurs si on se compare
on se rassure
je te remercie nathalie est
effectivement notre grand temps je sais
ça comment embarqué tout le monde avec
les diversité des situations les
diversité des modes de vie
et dans les
objectifs et contingences de notre
xxième siècle où tout le monde a bien
compris que la notion environnementale
sera majeur et nous avons là une une
responsabilité collective et je crois
que c'est jacqueline qui disait que nous
étions nous c'est
patrick que nous étions le parti de la
raison bien moi la raison c'est
éminemment moderne quand j'entends
les les débats actuels quand je vois les
crispations quand je vois les les
crispations que ces débats génère
l'incompréhension de nos concitoyens
quelquefois aussi mia je crois que la
raison elle doit être portée aux efforts
parce que la raison elle rassure puis la
raison c'est le fils pour tout
simplement que nous puissions poursuivre
dans notre démocratie donc faire en
sorte nos démocrates continuent à aimer
les gens partout ils habitent sur nos
territoires allez comprendre à
comprendre les situations à n'a pas créé
de situations clivante pas par démagogie
mais tout simplement pour embarquer les
uns et les autres sur dans notre dans
nos objectifs démocratiques
il nous a pas échappé que ben parlions
d'abstention hier soir c'est quand même
quelque chose de très très inquiétant et
tout cela paraît bien raisonnable mais
en fait je crois que il n'y a que de
cette façon là que nous continuerons à
être à vivre dans un pays que beaucoup
nous envient et donc soyons toujours
dans ce combat et ne perdons jamais de
vue que les hommes et les femmes ou
qu'ils soient où qu'ils habitent doivent
avoir toute notre attention et quel que
soit leur mode de vie et je crois que
c'est ça qui fait notre force parce que
les démocrates
eh bien nous sommes dans cet état
d'esprit
j'ai beaucoup de chance d'être assise à
côté de marc fesneau mais marc fesneau a
la chance d'être à côté de moi il a pu
lire ma question
important que vous le sachiez
vieilles habitudes j'étais pas très
bonnes et
m'a fait ne vous n'êtes inconnu de
personnes mais il me revient de rappeler
que vous êtes ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne
si j'ose dire le ministère rêvé pour un
démocrate vous qui francis est
quotidiennement la ligne entre le
parlement et les assemblées citoyennes
comment selon vous pour nous réconcilier
demande
qui peine à se comprendre
cette question me surprend
les peaux le temps de la préparer
eux l'agapa bonjour à toutes et à tous
le mot réconciliation et à ses juges je
pense pourtant c'est pas de monde c'est
la même chose et une démocratie c'est un
tout c'est des représentants qu'on élit
au niveau national et au niveau local
d'air
c'est aussi des syndicats j'en dirai un
mot une organisation professionnelle qui
représente telle ou telle corporation
tel ou tel secteur et puis c'était des
citoyens mais tout ça est un tout et
c'est vrai qu'on s'est peu à peu
construit le sentiment en tout cas
vis-à-vis du monde politique mais
finalement pas mon avis pas que
vis-à-vis du politique
que le monde politique n'est d'abord ne
représentait pas les citoyens au sens
premier du terme c'est que les gens ne
ne reconnaissait pas dans leurs
représentants des gens qui étaient issus
de leurs rangs
et deuxième chose c'est qu'ils ne
représentaient pas
ce qu'attendaient les sites web et cette
fracture elle et elle ce qu'elle est
creuse elle s'est creusé et elle est
très compliqué
à résorber pour mon avis plusieurs
raisons
la première c'est que je pense qu'il
faut qu'on essaye en permanence parce
qu'on est dans un monde qui est
extrêmement complexes où les décisions
qu'on prend sont extrêmement complexes
et donc les nécessités d'explication de
ce que nous faisons sont beaucoup plus
grandes et au fond c'est quand même une
chose assez saine je trouve que les
citoyens ne nous donne pas quitus
éternel demande des comptes sur ce qu'on
fait
ce qu'ils étaient avant quelque chose
d'assez verticale mais je pense qu'il
faut de la verticalité société en mai
quelque chose qui était totalement
verticale n'est plus accepté les gens
disent mais vous faites ça vous fait ça
pourquoi comment est ce que c'est pour
moi que vous le faites
ça c'est un premier sujet de difficulté
le deuxième sujet des difficultés je
pense c'est que on est dans un moment
françois l'a dit hier ou avant-hier j'ai
une anse théière forcément
où
tout était est ébranlée tous les
systèmes sont ébranlés et ce qui faisait
aussi le fondement d'une décision
publique c'était
la raison la science le procès ce qui a
amené à la prise de décision est battu
en brèche qui fait que c'est très
difficile de prendre une décision quand
on a face à soi ou à côté de soi ou des
citoyens qui remettent en cause même le
fondement de ce pourquoi on prend la
décision comment pouvait renoncer est
assez marginal en france mais je pense
pas que ce soit tant marginal que ça et
mon avis ça montre à d'ailleurs comment
vous voulez parler et oeuvrait pour le
réchauffement pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique quand il ya des
gens qui pensent que ça n'existe pas
parce qu'évidemment par nature le
fondement même de la première décision
que vous prenez elle est battue en
brèche par des gens qui disent ça
n'existe pas
troisième sujet c'est quand même le
sentiment qu'ont eu beaucoup de gens
depuis très longtemps
que le monde politique que l'action
publique on va dire ça plutôt comme ça
était plutôt un puissant que puissant à
régler les problèmes du monde parce que
dans l'espace monde le sentiment qu'on
était trop petit et c'est là que mon
avis l'europe a toute sa place et tout
doit prendre toute sa plénitude parce
que c'est dans cet espace là qu'on
retrouve sa puissance
est par ailleurs que nous ne parlions
pas assez des sujets du quotidien il
semblait souvent on en parlait hier à la
table ronde où j'étais entre autres avec
jacqueline
avec les mots qui ne sont pas les mots
du quotidien des gens ont jargonne en
acronymes is on passe son temps à dire
des choses que les gens comprennent pas
ça c'est une 23e sujet de difficulté
puis quatrième sujet difficulté me
semble-t-il c'est un sujet de
difficultés on va être dans un moment
d'assez fortes contraintes sur les
décisions politiques
on sait ce que sont les contraintes de
des décisions qui sont à prendre pour
lutter contre je reviens sur la question
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique mais au fond on pourrait nous
dire à quoi sert le politique puisque
toute façon on sait à peu près ce qu'il
faut faire
ou ce qu'il faut pas faire plus tôt
d'ailleurs
jeudi sous l'oeil de gens qui suivent
ces questions là je vois bruno dans mon
nom mon scops et d'autres et ça serait
de compliqué parce que vous allez
devenir devenir devant revenir devant
des gens et peut-être dire à peu près
tous la même chose et comment vous
donner le sentiment que du coup quand
vous élisez des gens ils peuvent avoir
une part d'autonomie dans la décision
publique donc ça c'est quand même dans
la difficulté et puis dernier point je
voulais levées là dessus c'est une leçon
qu'on a un sujet
qui est une demande permanente une forme
de demande de démocratie continue
de pouvoir élire des jambes et en
permanence pouvoir réinterroger les
questions qui sont soumises alors qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour faire vite
parce que le temps court et c'est bien
qu'on est peut-être un échange le plus
immédiat camarades qui vont qui vont en
parler mais
moi il me semble que un essai ministre
des relations avec le parlement qui dit
ministre relations avec le parlement et
ancien parlementaire je pense qu'il faut
qu'on renforce le pouvoir du parlement
il faut qu'on aille plus loin sur cette
question là parce que évidemment si on a
des parlementaires qui sont plus à même
de porter de la décision ça
crédibilisera des choses et je pense que
cela n'affaiblit pas le gouvernement je
pense que ça le renforce parce que ça
évite qu'il soit seul dans sa décision
finale et confond on dit bah c'était
votre initiative donc ça c'est un
premier élément
je pense qu'on a besoin ce quinquennat
aura été marquée en revanche par une
devrait avancer alors avec ce que saad
chaotique de ce que ça d'expérimental ce
que sa difficulté autour des processus
de participation citoyenne on a beaucoup
dauber sur la question de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat c'est des
discussions qu'on a eues y compris avec
françois
mais je pense que ce qu'on a essayé de
faire les moments intéressants
y compris de confrontation pour les
citoyens avec les sujets durs et il ya
un certain nombre de sujets qui ont été
mis sur la table
et les parlementaires qui sont impliqués
dans cette affaire ça permet aussi de
montrer ce qui est faisable et ce qui
est en fait tout le champ et la marge du
politique c'est ce qu'on voudrait ce
qu'on devrait et puisqu'on peut c'est
comme ça aussi qu'il faut essayer de
combiner dans ce genre d'affaires et ça
a permis ça je pense de commencer à
réfléchir comme ça on a besoin de
travailler des processus comme ça sur
des tas de sujets ce sujet-là été très
longue et très complexe que répondre à
la question - 40 % en 2030 n'est pas une
question simple pour personne d'ailleurs
ni pour des citoyens juste il éclairait
ni pour qui que ce soit je pense que
c'est un élément important sur lesquels
il faut réfléchir et puis la question
est donc et de et d'essayer de trouver
des formes et tout le monde cherche dans
beaucoup de pays on cherche au niveau
local au niveau national mais en
rappelant une règle assez simple pour
moi c'est au final c'est politique celui
qui a été élu pour le faire qui prend
une décision parce que sinon c'est ça ne
peut pas être une oeuvre ce dialogue ait
cette frontière que parfois certains
entretiennent ça ne peut pas être une
oeuvre qui soit une oeuvre de démolition
de la démocratie représentative parce
qu'à la fin si on démolit la démocratie
représentative je pense qu'on démolit la
démocratie c'est aussi simple que ça
donc on a besoin de nourrir la
démocratie représentative d'un dialogue
était citoyen qui passe par exemple par
des process de démocratie participative
et je suis certain que ça passe aussi
par le fait de renforcer sa peut pas
être une oeuvre pour saper la démocratie
représentative j'entendais jean luc
mélenchon a expliqué que le procès ce
qui pourrait être le référendum
révocatoire c'est à dire que tous les
six mois où tu as ou à tout moment on
peut dire d'un élu je leur envoie parce
que je prend pas des décisions celle
inverse de la décision publique faire ça
parce qu'on continue quand on prend des
décisions publiques c'est pas forcément
populaire et donc si à chaque fois qu'un
dé lui prend une décision impopulaire on
le met sous la menace je parle même pas
des affaires des affaires juridiques qui
sont une deuxième à mon avis deuxième
sujet du cadre dans lequel nous évoluons
s'il est sous la menace de
l'impopularité alors je sais ce qui va
se passer c'est l'immobilisme et à la
fin c'est la loi du citoyen le plus fort
c'est à dire de la violence il s'exprime
donc voilà ce que je vois ce que je sens
moi j'étais pas je le dis très
honnêtement un
juge comme c'est comme l'eau comme
l'autre qui faisait de la prose sans le
savoir je faisais sans doute un peu de
participation citoyenne sans le savoir
d'ailleurs la première participation
citoyenne c'est aussi des devises parmi
les gens à peu près normalement et je
pense qu la première oeuvre utile d'un
responsable public c'est de continuer à
vivre à peu près comme tout le monde
même si on ne peut pas vite totalement
comme tout le monde mais la première
c'est de vivre parmi les gens de vivre
comme les gens parce que c'est là mais
ça vous évite d'avoir besoin de lire des
sondages ou des gens qui vous explique
ce que les gens pensent que si vous
savez ce qu'ils vous pensez comme les
gens ne se serait plus fastoche pour
être représentants des citoyens ça c'est
à mon avis un élément central de la
posture du politique je lisais beaucoup
de trucs sur les gangs et la merkel
avait quelque chose d'intéressant dans
ce qu'elle est de ce point de vue là
mais ça c'est la première chose et après
il faut qu'on prenne moi je pense que le
responsable politique qui doit à la fois
écouter les citoyens et c'est valable au
niveau local comme au niveau national et
après prendre ses responsabilités on
évite des gens pour prendre des
responsabilités pas pour se soumettre
à des contraintes que les gens ne
veulent pas accepter voilà merci
merci mais il fallait super note
en atelier limaces vous êtes secrétaire
d'état chargés d'éducation prioritaire
j'avais une question pour vous mais
avant de monter sur scène je vous ai
demandé qu'est ce que le mouvement
démocrate et quel était le plus grand
combat du mouvement démocrate et vous
m'avez dit la famille elle n'était pas
dans ma question donc je vous laisse en
parler librement et vous avez vos cinq
minutes merci pauline oui c'est vrai
famille au mouvement démocrate on vous
aime
d'ailleurs c'est un sujet qui est dans
notre adn qui a été porté et défendu par
françois
ça fait l'objet d'un rapport l'année
dernière à l'assemblée nationale
j'ai été soutenue largement par mon gros
par le parti par mon président groupe
par mon ancien président de groupe en ce
sens
pendant trois ans avec mes amis députés
nous n'avions de cesse plfss après plfss
même plf d'ailleurs de rappeler
combien nous sommes attachés à cette
politique combien nous souhaitons
restaurer l'universalité cher stanislas
et combien nous souhaitons revenir aussi
sur les coups de rabot porté au quotient
familial alors il n'est jamais trop tard
évidemment puisqu'il ya encore un tunnel
budgétaire qui arrive et voilà je lance
un appel peut-être pourrions-nous
crantée avant la fin du quinquennat
quelques belles mesures pour la famille
alors je suis un peu agacé quand
j'entends les uns et les autres parler
de politique familiale notamment la dans
le cadre de la campagne
par exemple quand j'entends eric zemmour
pas encore tout à fait candidat mais
peut-être bientôt nous dire que la
famille elle est blanche hétérosexuels
deux enfants un chien et je ne parle pas
du prénom des enfants eh bien ça ça
n'est pas nous quand j'entends la droite
dira oui et limaces elle a rendu un
rapport en mai façon c'est un rapport de
droite non la famille n'est pas préempté
par la droite quand j'entends valérie
pécresse
faire ses propositions
jean noël tu me feras penser il faut
qu'on dédicace le rapport parce qu'en
fait elle a repris nos propositions
voilà donc vraiment il y a quelque chose
à faire je pense que bien sûr il ya eu
de belles mesures il y a eu la prime de
naissance il y a le congé de paternité
il ya même le congé de proches aidants
puisque pour nous la famille c'est tous
les âges de la vie c'est la petite
enfance l'enfance la conciliation entre
la vie familiale et la vie
professionnelle
et puis nos aînés donc oui il y a eu ces
mesures mais je crois qu'il faut aller
encore plus loin
je regardais une étude récemment selon
laquelle
les français ne sont pas en colère ils
ont besoin d'être rassurés et bien je
crois qu'il faut donner confiance aux
familles et nous avons vraiment les
moyens de le faire en tout cas je pense
que c'est le moment et qu'il faut
vraiment que nous saisissions de ce
sujet de cet enjeu et que nous portions
haut et fort nos propositions alors on
l'avait fait dans le rapport jean noël
on avait notamment évoqué des mesures
fiscales on va pas s'abreuver de
chiffres mais simplement pour se
rappeler que les deux coups de rabot qui
ont été portées au quotient familial par
les deux présidents les deux précédents
présidents de la république eh bien
c'est un coût pour les familles les
familles moyennes et même la tranche
basse de cette classe intermédiaire qui
a perdu à peu près 790 euros de pouvoir
d'achat
voilà voilà un sujet on peut parler de
l'universalité on peut parler de la
modulation des allocations familiales
qui finalement est ce qui a été retirée
aux 1 n'a pas profité aux autres ça
n'est donc même pas une mesure sociale
est vraiment il faut revenir je crois
sur ces sujets on peut parler évidemment
de la conciliation entre la vie
familiale et la vie professionnelle pour
que les parents et notamment les femmes
s'engagent plus sereinement dans leur
vie professionnelle on pourrait parler
d'un service public de la petite enfance
on pourrait parler de mode de garde mais
derrière ce sujet de la politique
familiale que l'on souhaite plus
volontaire il y a d'abord un sujet c'est
celui de la démographie cher françois tu
l'as dit récemment
c'est un sujet et je crois je peux même
pas dire qu'il est devant nous il est
déjà là et il est déjà presque un peu
trop tard pour agir je vais vous
redonner un chiffre qui pour moi être
édifiant éloquent cette année là à la
rentrée de septembre 2021 si on regarde
le quinquennat on a inscrit dans nos
écoles - deux cent mille élèves voilà
rien que ça je crois que ça doit nous
parler à tous et qu'il est donc urgent
d'agir pour relancer la natalité en
france pour donner confiance aux
familles et puisque c'est le thème de
l'art de la table ronde cher pauline
conscience et responsabilité est bien en
conscience et en responsabilité je nous
demande je vous demande de porter haut
et fort cette ce sujet cette thématique
de la politique familiale une politique
familiale volontariste
j'avais plaidé pour un family act à la
française il n'est pas trop tard la
campagne s'ouvre et je crois que c'est
le bon moment
vous m'accorderez la dernière question à
sarah et là éric qui est secrétaire
d'état chargée de la jeunesse et de
l'engagement mais aussi porte parole de
notre mouvement
et à voir porte ça va
il faut remarquer aussi que on va
s'accorder peut être une question un peu
plus féministe parce qu'il ya plus de
femmes que d'hommes sur ce plateau
il faut le souligner
et marc fesneau nous en veut pas
alors ça rate situer au delà de ton
portefeuille à faire sauter le plafond
de verre pour les jeunes mais aussi pour
les femmes alors quels conseils tu
donnerais à une femme qui veut se lancer
en politique
elle va dit donc
merci pauline moi je pense que on a deux
choses
avant les mots c'est de le faire c'est
de le faire c'est de le faire vraiment
est en fait de le prouver on est dans
une période où effectivement alors il ya
des chiffres et des rapports qui montre
la défiance le manque de confiance dans
la vie politique dans tout en réalité et
donc pour casser ces plafonds de verre
il faut montrer l'exemple et c'est marc
qui parlait d' exemplarité de comment tu
prouves comment tu prouves que ce que tu
dis c'est vrai et aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est un des gros combat un des
grands combats dans notre famille dans
notre famille politique
en fait on le fait la preuve qu'ils ont
commencé en disant il ya plus de femmes
sur ce plateau en tout cas sur cette
tribune à ce moment là c'est vrai c'est
concret il ya trois générations c'est
concret mais au-delà de ça si si on
regarde si on a passé on a passé trois
jours ensemble et finalement en
discutant se retrouvent dans nos combats
on est des militants et des bâtisseurs
donc on n'accepte pas ce plafond de
verre quel que soit le chemin quelle que
soit l'histoire on est un des seuls
mouvements qui n'est pas monocolore ça
veut dire quoi très concrètement ça veut
dire qu'on vienne d'un territoire plus
rurales ou d'un territoire plusieurs
bains convives en centre ville ou dans
un quartier que l'on soit finalement
très très éclairé les traits ou qu'au
contraire et bien on ait le goût de
l'engagement associatif de la mission
locale dont on a notre place ici et nos
échanges le proof conçoit un passionné
de rock parce qu'on l'a vécu parce que
on y fonde nos espoirs ou parce qu'on
adore ses institutions et la démocratie
est le projet qu'elle porte on a notre
place et tu vois ce plafond de verre on
le casse d'abord si on prouve que c'est
possible dans notre pays et je crois que
c'est le combat de françois françois tu
le dis tu le répètes jamais tu
accepteras que dans une cour d'école
es-tu là encore d'hier eh bien on
regarde quelqu'un on lui dise tu n'as
pas ta place tu n'es pas français alors
même que les discours les plus
nauséabonds sont en train de prendre de
l'ampleur dans notre pays alors même que
et la droite et la gauche nous divisent
essaye de finalement 2-2 d'alimenter
cette colère cette méfiance ça sent pas
bon parce que c'est pas notre histoire
parce que fondamentalement c'est pas
fondamentalement c'est pas notre
héritage et c'est certainement pas notre
france notre société et donc pour casser
ces plafonds de verre on est des
démocrates des humanistes il faut de la
rencontre moi je crois au mentorat je
crois à ces rencontres humaines on a
tous quelqu'un qui a un moment dans sa
vie te fais confiance moi je n'oublierai
jamais le premier dîner avec marc avec
france soir mais c'est vrai marc je
pense que tu te souviens je crois que
dans ma fédération devait être 15
ya quelques mais
ouais je mets ces rencontres ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya un
moment il ya quelqu'un qui te regarde et
qui te dit
tu as ta place tu as touche mais en fait
je vais donner un veto détache en ce
sens que tu viennes prouver ou
qu'on te demande quelque chose en
échange et cette confiance elle t'oblige
toi au contraire à la redonner derrière
à regarder les gens avec finalement une
présomption positive simplement en se
disant que oui chacun quelque chose à
apporter et donc seulement torres
tutorale présente la république l'a
souhaité à grande ampleur alors moi je
suis une militante et jeu que ce que ce
soit dans notre partie ou dans nos eaux
dans les assauts et bien on a créé et
fait converger un peu comme ce qu'on est
en train de faire avec nos mouvements
avec la république en marché et
évidemment nous on a fait converger les
énergies on a réuni tous ceux qui font
du tutorat et du mentorat dans nos
territoires et on a créé en tout cas on
accompagné la naissance du collectif
mentorat plus de 30 millions d'euros
pour permettre à chaque association et
bien soin de former les mentors soit
d'aider parfois simplement autre ag est
en tout cas de permettre des rencontres
rien ne remplacera le lien humain rien
ne remplacera ce regard rien ne
remplacera cette discussion parce que
parfois on a le soutient dans sa famille
et parfois on l'a pas et la mère des
batailles et pour le coup franchement je
sais qu'en le disant on est chez nous et
ça et ça résonne mais la mère des
batailles c'est l'école c'est celle qui
finalement quel que soit ce qui se passe
dans ton chez toi dans ta famille et
bien finalement te donne les outils les
outils pour bâtir les outils pour te
défends des outils pour t'exprimer pour
que finalement tu ne sois pas ni blessé
ni n'est finalement de poser les armes
et durban je suis condamné à rien jamais
dans notre pays on sera condamné à
quelque chose et c'est pour ça que l'on
tombera pas dans l'essentialisme on
reste des universalistes alors ça veut
pas dire
ça veut pas dire que tout est parfait
oui on a on a des sujets qui méritent
d'être bousculé d'être dit c'est pour ça
que nous on ose conscience et
responsabilité on met les mots on est
vite on n'a pas de tabou oui il faut
parler de cette discrimination bien sûr
il y en a quand tu cherche un job quand
tu veux louer un appartement et que ce
soit par rapport à ton nom et ton
quartier que ce soit même par rapport à
ta situation citées par an peuvent pas
être garant tu choisis pas les mêmes
études parce que finalement ils n'ont
pas les moyens de t'accompagner et donc
du coup parfois tu mens et hier la table
de la discussion c'était un témoignage
assez honnête une jeune fille qui dit
ben moi j'ai un cdd alors j'ai menti
j'ai dit que j'étais étudiante pour
pouvoir louer bas face à ça c'est quoi
notre promesse c'est de permettre à
chacun juste d'être pleinement ce qu'il
est de ne pas avoir peur et donc face à
ces situations
on les regarde en face on ouvre une
plateforme de lutte contre les
discriminations pour libérer la parole
et la combattre partout et on sera
jamais dans la hiérarchie oui c'est
grave quand tu as des propos homophobes
ou oui c'est gras frais des propos
racistes oui c'est grave quand ils sont
antisémites mais jamais on y re archi
sera jamais on opposera parce que
fondamentalement on lutte contre toutes
ces inégalités et de l'autre côté alors
oui oui oui on lui dit chacun à sa place
chacun quelque chose à apporter qu'il
ait ou pas diplômes parce qu'on peut
apprendre toute sa vie parce qu'on peut
apprendre en dehors de l'école et c'est
le grand combat de françois et c'est le
nôtre et finalement c'est ce qui moi me
donne aujourd'hui cette énergie parce
que notre pays les il a cette
responsabilité de dire les choses pour
pas laissé
vidé de toute leur énergie notre
jeunesse elle est diverse chacune mérite
un chemin chacune mérite son
accompagnement et c'est ce qui permet de
casser ces plafonds de verre alors
mesdames mais plus largement les amis si
on avait un hautmontois quand je croise
quelqu'un je vous dit deux choses la
première c'est aux aux être audacieux
poussette porte
même si le cv même si le diplôme tu l'as
pas demande et cei et en même temps aux
l'humilité l'audace et l'humilité
l'humilité de dire je sais pas et c'est
pas grave mais j'ai envie d'apprendre et
je suis prêt à prendre
je n'ai pas mais si tu me montre comment
faire je suis prêt et finalement la
conjugaison de cette audace et de cette
humilité elle permet à chacun de
reprendre le volant de sa vie ne pas la
subir donc finalement un seul mot oui la
force notre force chez nous et bien
c'est l'humanisme finalement c'est que
ça merci
je vais à présent vous proposé de poser
vos questions à la personnalité
si j'ai un passeur de micropole
soyez pas timides
jamais monsieur la bac
je vous remercie de m'avoir de nous
avoir donné la parole je me présente je
m'appelle farid in some soudain des
poteaux
nous sommes honorés d'être parmi vos
heureux
pour moi c'est pas une question mais
céiste pour donner
définition des mots qui sont marqués sur
les tableaux conscience et
responsabilité
l'ambition démocrate pour nous cela veut
dire un triangle
construite dans un cercle et les trois
trains un point du trio commence par
l'émotion
la raison et la prise des décisions
ensuite si vous nous permettez des
données la définition de démocratie pour
nos démocraties
est un pacte qu'est ce qu'un pacte c'est
un accord ou une convention solo n'est
mis en place pour préserver
la raison humaine merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]
c'était très beau et je pense qu'on peut
passer à la prochaine question
je serais vous j'aurais plein de
questions
vraiment bien
[Applaudissements]
tanguay à une question
[Musique]
oui
j'ai toujours éventuellement une
question c'est possible mais très
sérieusement en fait c'est on va
commencer une élection présidentielle
est on pas d'ambition démocrate
par rapport aux questions qu'on a eue
hier sur la loi nôtre et je regarde un
peu jacqueline gourault pendent premier
quinquennat on a dit on fera pas un big
bang territorial
est ce que le moment n'est pas venu pour
l'élection présidentielle de revoir la
loi notre de rééquilibrer territoire et
de donner plus de poids aux régions
et pas aux métropoles et en redonnant
peut-être en révisant la carte des
régions sur un plan démocrate et
territoriales sert des régions qui sont
cohérentes d'un point de vue historique
géographique et culturelle est-ce que
c'est pas le bon moment pour le faire
dans un deuxième quinquennat
éventuellement
[Applaudissements]
le commentaire de marc fesneau ses
applaudissements des bretons
[Applaudissements]
d'abord pour répondre à ce que tu viens
de dire non effectivement nous n'avons
pas fait de big bang territorial le
président de la république est resté
fidèle à ce qu'il avait dit et qui était
en fait la volonté exprimée des élus
locaux
d'arrêter les réformes territoriales
parce que depuis
remonte pas très loin donc il y a eu
beaucoup de réformes territoriales je ne
sais pas si michel mercier et dans la
salle mais il est là on a commencé à en
2010 avec la réforme des collectivités
territoriales la loi r c'est échéant
michel et puis il y a eu effectivement
beaucoup de lois pendant le quinquennat
de françois hollande aussi sur la
réforme les réformes au fonds
institutionnels des collectivités
territoriales donc les les élus avaient
besoin d'une pause et l'exprimer et
c'est ce que nous avons fait et bien
évidemment nous avons
légiféré tout de même mais chaque fois
et nous le ferons encore avec la loi 4d
pour donner des outils nouveaux pour
simplifier pour respecter la
différenciation de la différence des
territoires etc etc mais naturellement
et pour avoir eu déjà quelques
discussions
avec le président de la république
on sait bien que
il y a des choses qu'il faut faire
évoluer et ce que j'ai entendu alors je
tiens tu parles de la luano la loi notre
elle a une qualité et un défaut c'est
qu'on met tout sur le dos de la noix
nôtre il n'y a pas eu que des mauvaises
choses 2
décidée dans la loi notre notamment les
clarification des compétences qui d'une
manière générale était souhaitée mais
j'entends beaucoup de gens qui me
raconte que la loi notre si c'est le
découpage des régions où le redécoupage
des régions s'étaient pas dans la loi
nôtre c'était une autre loi ceci dit on
sait très bien
que le découpage le dis très clairement
le découpage des régions a été
enfin comment dire une plaisanterie si
je puis dire rater et
là la grosse erreur de la méthode quand
cela a été fait c'est d'avoir pensé
qu'on ne pouvait découper les régions
quand on pouvait justement pas découpées
on ne pouvait changer les régions que
par bloc c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
permis je dirais de faire du découpage à
l'intérieur des blocs et je crois que ça
a été une grosse erreur de ceux du
quinquennat de françois hollande alors
bien sûr il y aura dans la campagne
présidentielle
et c'est nécessaire un projet en
direction des collectivités
territoriales et je crois que tout ce
que nous avons fait pendant ce premier
quinquennat nous servira bien sûr pour
construire une réflexion et se projeter
dans l'avenir avec des idées
que les élus attendent toujours les
mêmes 1 c'est à dire des idées de
simplification des idées de liberté
locale des idées aussi de
responsabilités c'est bien conscience et
responsabilité
parce que il faut aussi que les élus ne
où les collectivités locales se sentent
responsables aussi de la mission qui est
la leur sur les territoires le président
de la république le dis souvent
il ya une tendance à toujours demander
plus de compétences pour les
collectivités territoriales mais ses
compétences elles ne peuvent s'exercer
et se comprendre que si il y à aussi la
responsabilité des compétences qu'on
vous a donné donc conscience et
responsabilité
merci
je voulais juste compléter sur ce point
là je trouve que ce qu'on est à l'heure
des bilans quinquennaux comme on dit je
trouve que le grief qui nous a été fait
depuis 2010 est jeudi sous l'oeil de
jacqueline qui à vrai depuis 2010 est
sur ces sujets là mais globalement le
gouvernement le président de la
république et les premiers ministres
successifs le
grief qui nous est fait sur la question
territoriale est agréé assez de mauvaise
foi pour patty retrait de mauvaise foi
est particulièrement injuste que je
voulais juste complété par ça et là
question de temps qu'il soulève
le vrai le sujet et c'est pas d'ailés
des questions de l'intérieur de
l'appropriation par les citoyens de
juger le vrai sujet pour moi
comment dirais-je de mépris à l'endroit
des territoires il a été posée le jour
on a décidé de découper des régions sur
un coin de table dimanche soir avec
plusieurs versions de cartes et avec un
mépris absolu de ce qui était l'histoire
la culture les traditions des
territoires je vais pas me faire donner
la leçon par des gens qui ont fait ça
n'ont pas pour des contingences de ce
qui était historiquement
vécu comme tel le parcours des régions
et de leur territoire quand vous
regardez le découpage du grand est quand
vous regardez le découpage de
l'occitanie enfin il ya comme un certain
nombre de régions de la nouvelle
aquitaine
on a on a fait une violence au
territoire et à ce qui était leur
histoire qui est très forte et la
deuxième chose qu'on a fait c'est qu'en
plus on a on a produit
2 l'identitarisme à surproduire
identitarisme locale parce que dans
cette ce sentiment de nier l'identité
territoriale dans les grandes régions on
a fait ressurgir
parfois c'est assez durement je pense au
grand test mais pas courante est d
identité qui était très compliquée lors
la bretagne n'a pas subi ça au moins
parce que là une identité forte alors
elle aurait une identité tellement forte
qu'elle pourrait avoir envie de
s'étendre à l'ouest
et la région centre val de loire aurait
envie de s'étendre alès de pardon et la
région centre val de loire aurait envie
dans le dès lors de s'étendre à l'ouest
les bretons et les gens du centre
pourrait faire oeuvre commune mais
mais je pense que quand même on a ya
beaucoup de citoyens qui ont très mal
vécu cette affaire là et il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont le sentiment quand vous
êtes habitants guirec on vous dit votre
capitale de région c'est à bordeaux faut
pas s'étonner que les gens après le
sentiment que le le centre de sion le
lieu de décision et éloignées et donc je
ne ferai pas donné la leçon par ces gens
là et je ne ferai pas donné la leçon non
plus parce qu'ils c'est la loi je crois
rct ou à marche forcée parfois fondées
des choses autour des intercommunalités
là aussi en tenant pas compte de ce qui
était la réalité des territoires et puis
ce qui dans le quinquennat précédent ont
pris 13 milliards oui il ya quand même
un moment il va falloir qu'on repose des
choses sur les questions territoriales
je pense que la question centrale et
jacqueline l'a10 et
il faudra réinterroger la question des
régions assez pacifiquement et là je
pense que le meilleur moyen c'est de
revenir ça a fait le jouet ce qu'est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est le
maire - c'est de réinterroger les
citoyens va pas de les ingérer interrogé
de les interroger en faisant une chose
incroyable c'est une fois qu'ils
auraient pris une décision c'est qu'on
la respecte
ou alors pour pas les interroger
mais yade il ya des moyens parce que je
pense qu'on y reviendra que si ça s'est
manifestée par une volonté territoriale
sinon on reviendra pas sur le découpage
des régions et donc ça c'est un élément
à mon avis qui est importante dans l'eau
et 2 je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit tous
adultes et que on assume la question de
conscience et responsabilité c'est à
dire que j'en ai un peu assez qu'on nous
dise tout le temps et moi je peux le
dire parce que 26 ans je suis conseiller
municipal et maire donc j'ai le droit de
le dire c'est à dire d'une injustice
crasse m'enfin moi je vais le dire quand
même c'est un moment qu'on vous donne
des pouvoirs vous commencez par les
exercer
et après on discutera du reste mais je
trouve que cette façon de se
déresponsabiliser quand ça va pas bien
c'est la faute de l'état et quand ça va
bien c'est grâce à moi il ya un
similaire d'ailleurs avec les affaires
européennes qui le choque un peu
merci
j'ai une question
deuxième essai
bonjour
je suis pas si on me vole
bonjour bague à la maire-adjointe de
reims le grand s marqué viens de parler
je vous ai entendu parler tout a été dit
tout est parfait il ya une chose que je
n'ai pas entendu mais dieu dame est géré
collègues on n'a pas parlé inclusion on
n'a pas parlé handicap il n'a pas de
place cette différence n'a pas de place
voilà c'était ça ma question et merci à
vous merci mon avis
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas parlé
d'inclusion il ya beaucoup de sujets
d'ailleurs dont on n'a pas parlé parce
que finalement on avait assez peu de
temps en tout cas on peut y revenir si
vous voulez à l'école puisque on y
travaille beaucoup à l'école pour rendre
notre école de la république toujours
plus inclusive on a beaucoup oeuvré
notamment pour mieux accompagner les aes
h pour leur donner un statut pour leur
donner pour revaloriser leurs indemnités
et puis de manière générale dans tous
les pans de notre société on fait en
sorte de la rendre toujours plus
inclusive mais c'est un sujet en entier
finalement et peut-être faudrait-il y
dédier y consacrer une table ronde et il
y a eu des ateliers me dit sarah mais en
tout cas c'est vrai c'était pas le thème
de ce matin est bien évidemment c'est un
grand sujet de préoccupation pour nous
tous
merci
je ne peux pas vous distribuez le micro
à distance mais
bonjour merci beaucoup pour vos
prestations toujours brillante et c'est
un bonheur d'être de partager cette
famille je j'ai une toute petite
remarque que vous connaissez mes dadas
aimé sujets fétiches
pauline tu as parlé tu a questionné ça
rassure les droits des femmes parce que
rafa
je recrée patrick notre cher ami en
prison c'est pas le respect de la ram ce
qu'il nous faut c'est le respect des
droits des femmes et donc je voudrais te
remercier nathalie à ben patrick earle
devons revoir ça mon loulou
mai
sarah tu je voudrais te remercier et
nous devons tous remercier pour ce que
tu as fait pour la protection des
enfants tu t'es battue comme une lionne
sur l'histoire du consentement et sur
l'âge c'est pas réglée il faudra y
reprendre y retourner et il faudra
reprendre le
travail et sur les droits des femmes oui
nous pouvons compenser que nous sommes
dans un pays très conforté sur la place
des femmes mais nous avons une
responsabilité à l'international et mes
amis en deux sur cette période
préélectorale je voudrais qu'on inscrive
et qu'on exige que soit inscrite dans
nos projets
pour cette élection
un engagement fort pour porter sur le
débat à l'international au-delà du débat
budgétaire
équilibre armée défense etc pour y
inscrire de manière indéfectible la
protection des femmes à l'international
parce que nous savons que depuis 30
elles sont malmenés par tous surtout en
afrique et que les assauts des dos droit
des femmes et notamment les la lutte
contre le sida ont été très malmené donc
nous avons un devoir et nous avons une
responsabilité et je vous remercie de
vous y inscrire merci
merci
oui otilia je vais te répondre sur le
premier point et puis sarah complétera
notamment sur le sujet de la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles commis
sur mineurs c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qu'on a beaucoup apporté au groupe
on était même un peu précurseur à
l'époque
mais en revanche je ne suis pas d'accord
avec toi il faut quand même le rappeler
on a avancé on avait demandé la fixation
d'un seuil d'âge de consentement on
était entre 13 et 15 ans on vient
d'avancer on avait voulu porter le débat
de la prescription on vient d'avancer
notamment avec le sujet de la
prescription glissante donc il ya encore
beaucoup à faire notamment je pense à
l'inceste
et en faire un sujet un crime spécifique
mais là aussi en avance on vient de
mettre en place en ligne une plateforme
les numéros de téléphone et d'ailleurs
depuis que c'est en ligne les
témoignages ne cessent d'arriver donc
oui il ya un faire mais on a quand même
progressé je voulais le souligner et
puis sur l'égalité femmes hommes avant
de te donner micro sahara on a avancé
aussi notamment à travers la loi à venir
et l'égalité salariale entre les femmes
et les hommes puisqu'on est passé d'une
obligation de moyens à une obligation de
résultat alors il a fallu un outil
législatif pour qu'on le fasse
manifestement ça n'est pas encore ancré
dans nos habitudes mais là aussi
charlotte il ya un an progresse
merci merci une autre question ça va
peut-être juste complété il y avait deux
sujets sains la question des femmes à
l'international quand aujourd'hui on
voit la situation en afghanistan les
familles aisées dit genre plus que
jamais s'il ya un endroit où on doit se
mobiliser et porter et les protéger et
accompagner leurs voix c'est chez nous
ça c'est notre responsabilité mais c'est
de notre espèce dans l'histoire et au
delà de ça des sujets de protection
aujourd'hui on en a et on en a besoin
pour les jeunes et les plus précaires je
pense aujourd'hui à la question de la
prostitution chez les jeunes je pense à
la question du jeu et l'addiction des
alors ce soit les jeux vidéo ou les
paris ces sujets là ils sont absolument
essentielles et c'est là où tout à
l'heure d'attali parler de famille il ya
comment on accompagne les familles parce
que plus d'une ne sait plus comment ça
se passe sur internet et donc les
enfants se retrouvent finalement
beaucoup plus tout seul et parfois livre
a même aidé ou parfois victimes
oui
j'ai une question que frédéric petit
c'est une réponse parce qu'il faut
vendre notre bilan otilia on a fait une
voix magnifique dont personne ne parle
c'est la loi bd programmation de la paix
des dans laquelle nous prévoyons loi
française que toute l'aide publique au
développement qu'elle vienne de l'état
qu'elles viennent des collectivités
qu'elles viennent des associations dans
les cinq priorités il ya
les droits des femmes dans tous les pays
où nous intervenons ce qui deviendra
maintenant obligatoire
et hugo qui a une question tout là bas
s'il vous plaît debout le jeune homme à
la chemise blanche
je prends pas de question juste après
bonjour donc je suis hugo jeunes
démocrates ce matin nous avons la
présentation de votre nouvelle charte
des jeunes démocrates et je pense que
finalement conscience et responsabilité
est ce que notre mouvement n'est pas
finalement au croisement d'un côté de
cette conscience de toujours se remettre
en question de toujours vouloir aller
plus loin toujours poussé finalement les
limites de nos enjeux comme par exemple
l'ambition portée avec la loi 4d par
exemple tout récemment mais toutes les
toutes les lois que ce sont l'engagement
que ce sont aussi l'engagement des
citoyens et puis également la
responsabilité de toujours questionné le
citoyen questionner notre notre peuple
finalement sur ses préoccupations du
quotidien est-ce qu'on n'est pas alors
en plus en tant que lyonnais à la
confluence finalement de ces deux enjeux
et surtout finalement à l'heure où les
partis historiques restent dans une
mobilité une immobilité presque totale
est-ce que nous mouvement démocrate
aussi cette dynamique que nous
souhaitons porter avec cette maison
commune est ce que c'est pas finalement
aussi tout cela aussi l'adn du parti
merci jean noël
oui merci le
le terme de conscience le terme de
responsabilité que vous avez retrouvé
dans l'intitulé de cette de cette table
ronde est et dans les propos qui ont été
tenus par nos responsables nationaux
c'est un clin d'oeil à cette phrase que
françois bayrou aime rappeler de marc
sangnier qui dit que la démocratie est
l'organisation politique qui pousse à
son maximum la conscience et la
responsabilité de chacun et je crois que
effectivement c'est important que cette
charte que vous avez adopté ce matin et
je félicite les jeunes démocrates
d'avoir pris cette initiative vient
c'est important qu'elles qu'elles
reflètent cette double dimension la
conscience c'est l'éveil des consciences
c'est à dire que nous pensons que les
dés
les citoyens doivent être pleinement
associés aux décisions qui sont prises
en leur nom et que c'est parce que nous
les associons qu'ils peuvent ensuite
prendre les responsabilités prendre
leurs responsabilités quel que soit leur
métier quels que soient leurs
engagements mais aussi comprendre et
participer à l'effort de réforme qui
parfois suppose effectivement un effort
suppose une vision de long terme et
quelles que soient les politiques ou
quelles que soient les réformes que l'on
envisage il faut toujours et c'est ce
que nous disons il faut toujours informé
éclairer les consciences pour que la
responsabilité puisse suivre je rentre
pas dans le détail mais sur l'égalité
hommes-femmes jeu je trouve
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
choses ont été faites même si le projet
comme je le disais tout à l'heure mais
n'est pas encore tout à fait achevée on
a eu l'occasion hier en matière
économique de parler de cet index
d'égalité homme femme qui désormais dans
les entreprises va permettre d'avancer
vers une plus grande égalité salariale
et sur les questions de handicap je
rappelle je rappelais tout à l'heure
certaines des grandes conquêtes mais la
pch c'est aussi une conquête démocrates
que nous avons consolidé grâce au
travail de philippe berta et c'est un
sujet qui a été au coeur de nos
discussions bien souvent au groupe même
si peut-être qu'il faut effectivement
aller beaucoup plus loin et on a eu
l'occasion il y compris sur des petites
anomalies d'en parler puisque on vous
nous rappeler tout à l'heure quand
devenant adjointe dans la ville de reims
vous avez perdu l'accès à la hache donc
encore beaucoup de scories beaucoup de
choses à corriger pour permettre une
pleine inclusion des personnes en
situation de handicap mais comptez sur
les députés du groupe modem et compter
sur le modem pour porter cette priorité
très haut merci
bon je mets ma question pour geneviève
ayant reste toujours effectivement sur
le vocable conscience et responsabilité
je le disais hier je déposé une gerbe en
mémoire d'un certain nombre de soldats
de la guerre d'algérie que la france a
oublié que la france a maltraité et
effectivement ça m'amène à te poser la
question à propos de toutes les familles
afghanes qui ont servi loyalement la
france et qui l'ont accompagné pendant
toutes ces années est ce que tu peux
nous dire nous promettre qu aucune de
ces familles ne soient oubliées comme
l'ont été effectivement ses soldats dont
je parlais tout à l'heure
alors nous sommes bien sûr dans un un
sujet difficile
la france s'est retirée pour ce qui est
des armées
d'afghanistan
depuis 2014 mais bien sûr il y a deux
après il ya eu persistance de tous nos
services diplomatiques dans le pays
pour ce qui est des armées françaises il
y a à peu près
alors c'est peut-être un peu moins un
peu plus un peu moins je crois
dit pcr l1 ce sont ces c
ces hommes et ces femmes et qui ont aidé
l'armée française à être interprète où
il pouvait être au combat pour certains
dans dans leurs actions de guerre dans
le pays et donc le recensement a été
réalisé et
pratiquement la majorité est en france
actuellement il faut le savoir quand
même et il faut savoir qu'il y en a un
grand nombre qui était déjà qu'ils
avaient déjà rejoint la france depuis
pas mal de deux mois voire d'années pour
certains est que depuis la
l'accélération liée au désengagement des
états unis
d'autres ont rejoint ont rejoint la
france il doit en rester à peu près je
parle des armées françaises je ne parle
pas des aides ceux qui ont aidé dans les
fonctions diplomatiques
il doit en rester
quelques dizaines en afghanistan
pour lesquels bien nous avons nous
suivons leur sujet et nous faisons tout
pour les ramener en france voilà mais la
très grande majorité de ces pc rl qui
ont aidé les armées sont en france avec
leurs familles actuellement il faut le
savoir
cette question
oui michel guégan militants membres
démocrates depuis très longtemps est
d'abord je remercie le mouvement
démocrate qui m'a beaucoup apporté pour
ma la vie d'élu
ma question est la suivante après avoir
créé avec quatre autres baer la première
communauté de communes de france en 1992
avec en 2006 nous avons créé à trop
commune une commune nouvelle et là je
dois dire que ce qu'a dit marc fesneau
tout à l'heure c'est que lorsque des
élus prennent une décision ils veulent
l'appliquer or la charte qui a été voté
à l'unanimité par les trois conseils
municipaux à la première réunion des
prochaines municipales de la commune
nouvelle elle était bafouée bafouée
notamment pour l appartenance à la
communauté de communes donc que je pense
c'est que la charpente comme une
nouvelle doit être obligatoire d'autant
plus que là quand elle est votée à
l'unanimité et ça me paraît quand même
essentiel qu'elle soit appliquée et même
les autorités de l'état ne loge pas fait
remarquer donc je crois ma question est
la suivante je souhaite que lorsqu'une
commune nouvelle est créée la charte
soit respectée et d'ailleurs michel
mercier a dit que la charte du combi
noël c'est la loi donc en l'occurrence
dans la commune nouvelle en question la
loi a été bafouée la charte des dents
étaient bafoués merci
twingo
voiles et j'ai très bien j'ai entendu je
connais très bien michel la situation
de la commune nouvelle de la chapelle
caro si ma mémoire est bonne
il ya un sujet parce que les communes
nouvelles au delà de la charte que et la
revendication que tu expliques je crois
qu'il faut expliquer que faire une
commune nouvelle c'est un engagement
important qu'il faut pas c'est
effectivement michel mercier qui a créé
les communes nouvelles en 2010 dans la
loi rct et il y a eu ensuite des
amodiations qui ont été faites bien sûr
notamment par jacques pélissard à
l'époque président de l'association des
maires de france
je je je dis ça à côté de marc fesneau
kim écoutent attentivement parce que
nous avons toujours beaucoup de débats
sur les communes nouvelles
les communes nouvelles il faut toujours
se dire que ensuite ce sont d une
nouvelle commune
je le dise a l'air un peu bizarre mon
truc mais je le dis quand même quand on
fusionne
des communes ensemble et ba ont fait une
nouvelle commune et il ya un laps de
temps qui a été
permis pour
assimiler pour
entrer dans le droit commun notamment
fiscales et c'est très intéressant de
voir que
quand les gens on les donnait au départ
bas il faut aussi les respecter jusqu'au
bout et parfois je sens que le mouvement
et c'est assez régulier d'ailleurs et
avec la loi cadre des gens n'entend
évidemment à nouveau parler que les gens
ont du mal à ce à comment dire à avoir
la conscience qu'ils sont dans une
commune nouvelle et il voudrait que
effectivement ça c'est intéressant de
parfois de faire les communes nouvelles
parce qu'il ya de la carotte c'est à
michel qu'il avait mis d'ailleurs
et qui s'y est opposé et parfois
l'opportunité des carottes
est quelque chose que les gens
voudraient voir advitam eternam
donc ça me permet de dire passer des
petits messages
réfléchissez bien quand vous voulez
construire une commune nouvelle il ne
faut pas faire de l' opportunité
parce que évidemment après on rentre
dans le droit commun est très important
et par ailleurs alors il ya des endroits
où ça a très bien marché je pense un
département de l'ouest comme le maine et
loire où
je pense aussi à la manche où il ya eu
beaucoup de communes nouvelles et ça
marche bien mais je note aussi que dans
et ce sera ma conclusion dans le maine
et loire ils ont eu l'intelligence de
faire des communes nouvelles mais ils
ont aussi l'intelligence en même temps
de refaire aussi des
intercommunalités qui ne tenait compte
de l'évolution
des communes voilà parce que au fond
tout ça fait un tout et au fond
l'intercommunalité quand elle a été
créée elle a été créée avec l'idée d'une
coopérative de communes et il faut
regarder toujours l' équilibre entre
communes et intercommunalités merci
bonjour philippe de longevialle isère
savoie les alpes et les montagnes
conscience et responsabilité sont deux
mots je trouve magnifique de la langue
française dont dit que science sans
conscience n'est que ruine de l'âme mes
décisions sans responsabilité c'est
vraiment la ruine de la démocratie marc
faisait tout à l'heure c'est difficile
d'argumenter de décider quand les gens
nient la réalité même du problème de la
question tu parlais du réchauffement
climatique mais on peut dire la même
chose sur la vaccination sur la corrida
c'est difficile d'argumenter quand les
gens nient la réalité même de la maladie
ou des solutions à 7 à cette maladie et
il ya un lieu où tout ça s'apprend tout
ça ce débat tout ça se développe ce lieu
c'est l'école l'école de la république
est ce que finalement l'ambition
démocrate s'est pas de replacer l'école
de la république au coeur de notre
projet au coeur de notre action
c'est un travail de long terme mais sans
ce travail là aucun projet durable qui
associe conscience et responsabilité
n'est possible
pour le coup on est tout à fait d'accord
la mère des batailles c'est l'école et
ça commence dès le plus jeune âge c'est
pour ça que il ya deux réponses c'est
comment on s'adapte à tous ces nouveaux
enjeux et donc comment on réunit des
jeunes qui ne se croisent pas avec le
service national universel des jeunes
qui ne se seraient jamais croisés parce
que leur vie leur famille leur lieu de
d'apprentissage comment on remet au
coeur également de l'école le chemin du
civisme le chemin du civisme c'est
finalement à nouveau ce respect
finalement ces outils finalement comment
tu peux prendre la mesure de ce qui
t'entoure mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
remettre au coeur la moderne certaine
manière re moderniser l'éducation
civique et morale remettre l'esprit
critique avec l'éducation aux médias et
tout ça tout ça en accompagnant en
réalité ce que non le plus besoin et
pour le coup je sais que c'est nathalie
qui le portent mais c'est le
dédoublement des classes de cp ce et 20
c'est le fait de permettre à chaque
jeune chaque enfant de manger le matin
et c'est son grand combat parce qu'il
n'apprend pas de la même manière s'il
n'a pas mangé et s'il a le ventre vide
et finalement c'est aussi le retour de
l'éducation populaire au coeur du
parcours parce qu'on apprend à l'école
est en tort de l'école en dehors de
l'école c'est comment on accompagne le
départ de d'enfants en vacances vacances
apprenantes parce que si tu ne pars pas
si tu ne respire pas si tu toxigène pas
finalement tu fais des tunnels et donc
et
je crois que c'était un signal pour que
je conclus ma réponse
alors barrette à tallinn
oui mais sarah a bien compté le sujet et
notamment je reviendrai très très
brièvement sur tout ce que nous avons
fait et porter pour l'école de la
république d'abord vous l'avez dit nous
avons laissé nos écoles ouvertes pendant
la crise sanitaire quand on se compare à
l'international ou même en europe on
voit que c'est une exception française
et c'est une fierté française
voilà nous avons laissé nos écoles
ouvertes pour lutter contre le
décrochage pour lutter contre l'échec
pour lutter aussi contre l' isolement
social et ça on ne le dit jamais assez
cette année nous avons fermé nos écoles
4 semaines dont deux semaines de congés
scolaires donc vraiment soyons fiers
pardon de ce que nous avons fait et de
la volonté très forte de jean michel
blanquer l'école c'est aussi le lieu de
de l'égalité des chances et on déploie
énormément de mesures pour lutter contre
les inégalités éducatives les inégalités
sociales sarah a parlé du redéploiement
des petits déjeuners gratuits à l'école
j'en ai parlé hier ça n'est pas une
mesure accessoires c'est une mesure
fondamentale parce que trop de nos
élèves arrivent à l'école le ventre vide
et puis c'est aussi le lieu où on lutte
contre les inégalités territoriales
parce que l'école doit doit elle est
partout et nos enfants doivent être
accompagnés
partout où ils sont en ville en quartier
en ruralité en zone de montagne etc etc
et bien sûr en outre mer je salue nos
amis ultramarins j'étais à la réunion
récemment et on se reverra prochainement
voilà merci
au delà de faire du bruit sur le plateau
est d'empêcher militaire marathon parler
juste rajouter deux choses la première
c'est ce qu'a dit jacqueline ouy patrick
site peut pas renverser la donne
au delà de ce que dit jacky sur les
communes nouvelles pour répondre à
michel aussi moi je n'ai jamais aimé les
trucs qu'on faisait c'est la carotte ou
le bâton parce que ce que les
collectivités sont pas des ânes quoi
et je pense que il faut que les
mouvements qui sont faits dans les
territoires s'adjoint d'ailleurs la
question qui avait anguille tout à
l'heure c'est des mouvements qui doivent
être des mouvements qui soit puissamment
portée par une volonté locale
et le tout aussi porté par une volonté
de compréhension par les citoyens de ce
qu'on est en train de faire et qu'ils
soient pas qu'on donne pas le sentiment
qu'on fait dans la rationalité la plus
évidente je gouverne pas par simplement
l'idée de la rationalité et savannah la
question aussi de philippe
tu as raison sur le fait que le
processus il est idée il doit être
démarré à l'école sauf que les défis
qu'on a devant nous sur des défis
d'urgence sur un certain nombre de
sujets qui vont nous obliger à la fois
sur le long terme a travaillé dans le
registre de l'éducation et donc du plus
jeune âge mais il faut qu'on trouve des
voies et moyens de dialogue et on l'a
réussi un peu à le faire au fond sur la
question vaccinale je rappelle que l'an
dernier à la même date on était à 70 %
de gens qui étaient opposés à la
vaccination est qu'aujourd'hui on est à
80% des gens vaccinés mais dont qu'on a
on a quand même réussi des choses et
donc qu'on en soit à la fois sur le
registre éducatif beaucoup plus puissant
sur plein de choses par moi j'ai vu dans
la crise de gilet jaune pour avoir faire
des premiers débats avec eux il y avait
jacqueline moureaux et pas gouro
monsieur drouet
il y avait plein de gens comme ça
sympathique sur le plateau j'étais un
peu frappé de la méconnaissance au-delà
des questions de de ce qui était le
fonctionnement de base des institutions
c'est pas je ne considère pas que ce
soit une génération perdue si je peux
dire parce que quand même si on est
juste on a beaucoup d'espoir pour ceux
qui vont être formés maintenant il faut
qu'on travaille sur ces questions là et
sur toutes les autres avec la cie des
citoyens que nous avons aujourd'hui est
donc je pense qu'on a travaillé sur les
deux registres mais je sais qu'on est
d'accord mais pour essayer d'avancer
parce que toutes ces transitions vont
nécessiter qu'on parle là dessus je vois
que c'est une conclusion à
merci je cède la parole à jean noël
barrot secrétaire général de notre
mouvement et je vous remercie et vous
souhaite une très bonne selon
l'université voilà on peut remercier
tous nos responsables restés à vos
places les discours à suivre dans
quelques instants